there's a reason they say best motion
picture for last it's the sum of all the
ingredients the end of a journey that
always starts with a dream and this year
those dreams were prompted by the j.r.r
tolkien Lord of the Rings trilogy by
Patrick O'Brian's massive Aubrey mature
in novels Laura Hilton brands tribute to
a fabled racehorse dennis lehane
hotly written crime drama and in a
moment when two disaffected characters
meet in a foreign landscape these then
of the nominees for Best Motion Picture
the Lord of the Rings The Return of the
King barium Osborn Peter Jackson and
Fran Walsh producers lost in translation
Ross Capps and Sofia Coppola producers
[Music]
Master and Commander the five side of
the world Sano Goldwyn jr. Peter Weir
and Duncan Henderson producers Mystic
River Robert Lorenz Judy seaport and
Clint Eastwood producers Seabiscuit
Kathleen Kennedy Frank Marshall and Gary
Ross producers and the Oscar goes to
it's a clean sweep the Lord of the Rings
The Return of the King Barry M Osborne
Peter Jackson and Sam walls producer
[Music]
this is the 11th academy award went
tonight for the Lord of the Rings The
Return of the King tying the record for
most wins with the film's Titanic and
Ben Hur
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I'm just waiting for friend to get
Orosco there we go oh this is just
unbelievable and I'm so honored attached
and relieved that the Academy and the
members of the Academy that supported us
have they've seen past the trolls and
the Wizards and the hobbits and a
recognizing fantasy this year fantasies
and if weird that hopefully the
five-second delay won't do anything with
I just want to say very few quick words
especially to the people of New Zealand
and the government of New Zealand and
the City Council's and everybody who's
supported us the length the length and
breadth of the country billy crystal's
welcome to come and make a film in New
Zealand any time he wants the special
thanks to Peter Nelson and Ken chemins
who were with me right from the days of
bad taste to meet the Feebles which were
which were wisely overlooked by the
Academy at that time and I especially
want to pay tribute to our wonderful
producer Barry Oz but when I please like
him to say a few words it's it's a great
honor to be here I start out in the
business 35 years ago getting people
coffee and I wonder if the fact that I
dated Billy Crystal's cousin so many
years ago has anything to do with
but it is really a great pleasure to be
in such great company I'm in trouble now
to be nominated with this floor other
Phil other four other great films and
after this these many years to receive
this award is a really a thrill for all
of us and we all thank the Academy it's
really a tribute to the talents of all
the people both in front of the camera
and behind the camera that we win this
award I want to thank in particular my
partner Carol
my beautiful daughter Danielle and my 87
year old dad who's that there in the
back somewhere here to celebrate this
with us I want to thank also jr. our
Tolkien and also the the fans that
supported us on this on this journey and
of course Bob Shaye and Michael Lynn
whose courageous venture allowed us to
make this film and their support
throughout the journey and mark or
deskey who worked alongside a side of us
throughout and became a great film of
the great friend sorry and of course to
Peter Jackson who was never satisfied
with a hundred percent but by his
example of pushing for a hundred and ten
percent he inspired all of us to do our
utmost to make these films and bring
them to the screen and finally to Wetty
who is in Chicago in Wellington New
Zealand and to the production team who
are in the Port Nicholson Yacht Club
it's time to celebrate
[Music]
a we related that elephants are not
related